Good morning, guys.
Welcome back to Gary's economics.
Today we're going to do a channel up date for you.
We've got a lot of things happening.
I want to make sure you guys know what's happening.
We're going to have some discount codes for you.
There's going to be some Easter eggs at the end.
Lots to talk about.
The first thing to say is
just thank you basically for
the reception coming back.
You know, people always tell you when you're doing
YouTube, never take a break. Never, ever take a break.
Always release weekly videos.
And that stressed me out, to be honest, because
it's difficult making a video every week.
And I want this to be a big political project
and I was worried that I wouldn't be able to keep weekly videos up.
You probably know that we took
six months off last year
and that was mainly to finish writing the book off.
But it was also partly because basically
sometimes I find making this channel quite stressful
and I needed a break
and I was worried that you guys might not be here
when I came back.
But we been getting more views than ever,
so yeah, thank you, everyone who's,
you know, waited for us to come back
and who still be there, who’s supporting,
who's spreading the message,
sharing the videos to your friends and family.
We appreciate that.
Second thing I want to say is
to talk about what's going on with the book.
In the last few weeks,
I've been doing
an unbelievable amount of book publicity,
which you won't have seen yet
because it's all being held back
basically to be released close to the time of release.
The book is coming out 5th of March.
Everyone is getting very excited.
We've had
photoshoots with three of the biggest broadsheets
in the country.
It feels like I've done interview
for basically every single newspaper in the country.
A lot of radio, a lot of TV.
It's all going to start coming in really quickly now.
So I wanted to talk about it on the channel
because basically in the next month
or so you're going to see a lot of me
on the TV, on the radio, in the newspapers. And
yeah, I wanted to make sure
you guys knew first and you were ready
if you want to keep up with what I'm doing,
we put this out on a lot of channels.
It's difficult
to post all of our media on a lot of the channel,
so you might want to follow me
on Twitter @garyseconomics,
and I'm going to post everything as it comes up.
We're going to try to keep it
on every channel so you can see what's happening.
But on things like TikTok,
for example it's not easy to post it, so
I don't think I've mentioned it yet,
but we've got book deals in, I think so far,
ten different countries, book deals in the UK,
US, Spain, Germany, Netherlands,
Finland, Czech Republic, Japan, China and Taiwan.
So all of those countries,
the book will come out in your local language,
but the English language version
will be available all over the world.
I have to give a shout out
to my American publishers
because they have been working
really hard to make sure
that we get a discount code for Barnes and Noble.
There've been more
and more American viewers in the channel recently.
I see you guys in the comments.
I've been on those guys because I know
we've been putting out the Waterstones
discount code here in the UK,
but we wanted to say something for the American’s.
So there will be at the time this video comes out,
we'll have the Barnes and Noble discount code
for American viewers
and it will be in the description below.
So make sure, if you're American,
thank you for your support. Check it out.
I know some of you are here just for the economics, so
we appreciate your patience for the book stuff.
But I also know a lot of you are here
supporting the book.
Listen,
everything is getting very exciting with the book.
I think we've got a really big opportunity
to reach a huge amount of people,
which is potentially going
to help us really grow this channel.
So I appreciate everyone who supported the book,
everyone who has preordered the book,
everyone who’s excited about reading the book.
Basically, I want you guys to be along for
what is going to be a pretty big adventure
the next month or two.
Lots of publicity, lots of media.
Yeah, I want you guys along for the ride
and I want you to enjoy it.
I think it's going to be a massive opportunity
to bring this message to way more people.
We might be able to grow the channel
potentially a lot, touch wood.
And make this channel big enough
that we can start influencing politicians.
You know, we've got,
we've got an election later on this year
in this country and in America,
and it'd be nice to be in a situation where
I can start pointing to these guys a little bit
and tell them where they need to go.
And the book is an opportunity to do that.
So thank you very much for your support.
The discount codes will both be below.
It's coming out UK and US March 5th.
Yeah, come with me man.
I'll be posting all of the media
and it's going to be an exciting time for me
and hopefully for you as well.
The next thing which I have to talk about is...
I don’t really...
I don't really like doing videos like this, but we hit
100,000 subs a few weeks ago,
so I wanted to say a big thank you to everyone
who has subbed to us, everyone who's been with us,
especially people
who've been with us a long time, since day one,
but also the new people as well.
But I also wanted to thank
Simran Mohan,
who is a friend of mine from high school, who
you see a lot of me on the channel, it’s a lot
my face, it’s a lot on my name.
But when I started this channel, it was June 2020
and at that time I was writing articles
for The Guardian and stuff and
basically I was getting pissed off
because I knew that,
you know, most of the people who are getting hurt
are ordinary people who,
you know, might not read The Guardian.
And I wanted to find a way to speak to,
you know, ordinary families
who are having their financial lives devastated.
And I really wanted to start a YouTube
and I was chatting about it on my
WhatsApp with my school friends
and a friend of mine named Simran Mohan,
who is a dentist,
reached out and said, look, I’ve got a camera,
let's just start shooting.
And
we shot videos together
for absolutely no money for a year and a half
and for very, very,
very little money for a year after that.
And he shot all the videos, he edited all the videos,
and we wouldn't be here without him.
And I know it's me on the camera and it's me, you see,
But in terms of hours,
it's him who put in a lot of the work.
So I wanted to give a shout out to him
to recognise 100,000 *subs
and also a shout out to all of you.
So thank you Simran, and thank you all
you guys as well.
Okay, I've got a couple of Easter eggs here,
so I wanted to answer a couple
of the most ridiculous questions
that we keep getting off on the channel,
which I don't normally answer in the comments.
Number one is, why do you wear that stupid hat
and those stupid gloves?
The answer is because it's winter and it's cold,
including sometimes in my house.
Number two is why do you speak in that stupid voice?
The answer is because I grew up in a stupid place
where everybody speaks in this stupid voice.
Those are the two Easter eggs.
Oh last thing is, yeah, I've got my...
I've shown the book on the channel before, but
that was a fake book with a fake graphic
because they hadn’t actually been printed yet.
So I've just received from Penguin,
hot off the press, the actual books.
So we're going to do an unboxing here.
We're doing all the tricks today. Here you go.
Here you go, this is the real thing.
This is it.
I don't know what to say, man.
Read it. You’ll like it. The last thing to say is
I know it's been a difficult time for a lot of people
and it's going to keep being difficult.
And I'm always aware when I make these videos
that I'm not
the person who's struggling
to put the heat on and I'm not the person
struggling to feed my family
or struggling to pay the bills, but
I'm working my tits off out here.
I know you haven't seen all the publicity I'm doing,
but I'm working eight days a week.
This is a massive opportunity to grow the channel.
I'm working as hard as I can.
I really appreciate all the support.
I hope people support the book because
I think that's our chance
to take it to the next level.
Stay there for each other.
It's going to be tough times ahead, but
as much as I can, I'll be out here making videos, so
thank you for your support.
And yeah, let's get to a million. Thank you.